المدى الزمني للنزاع الدائره حاليا في
السودان غير واضح لكن اجلاء الدول
للدبلوماسيه وايضا لرعاياها يؤشر لخطورته
وايضا طول امدح حيث تتواصل العمليات وجهود
اجلاء البعثات الدبلوماسيه ان كان العربيه
والاجنبيه والرعايه العرب والاجانب من
السودان مع استمرار المواجهات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع
فمسارعه الدول الغربيه طبعا بمقدماتها
الولايات المتحده لاجلاء دبلوماسيه واغلاق
السفاره مؤشر واقرار ضمن ربما بان الحرب
الدائره قد لا تتوقف قريبا قرار الدول بني
وفق مراقبين على استبعاد تسويه عبر
المفاوضات او حسم احد الطرفين المعركه
لمصلحته سريعا كما ان الخطوه الامريكيه
بارسال فريق استجابه للكوارث الى المنطقه
لتنسيق الاستجابه الانسانيه للمحتاجين
داخل وايضا خارج السودان يعني غياب اي
مساعد جديه او خطه ملموسه لوقف القتال في
السودان ليبقى السيناريو الاكثر ترجيحا هو
استمرار المعارك حينها كل طرف من اطراف
النزاع سيبحث عن داعمين له للصمود في
المعركه لاطول فتره ممكنه وبالتالي تعميق
الازمه بان هدنات عده فشلت وفرا الالاف من
السودانيين بحثا عن الامان ان كان الى
تشاد المجاوره الفقيره ففي الخرطوم حاليا
لاما لا كهرباء وايضا الوصول الامن للطعام
غير مكفول لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات